we are very grateful to be joined Now by
a man who can sort this out Victor Davis
Hanson who's a fellow at the Hoover
institution he joins us live uh
Professor thanks so much for coming on
so calling on people to harass Supreme
Court Justices where does this go do you
think
well we know where it goes It goes to
Nicholas Roski showing up at the home of
Brett Kavanaugh trying wanting to kill
him we have the most sustained attack on
the Supreme Court since the court
packing of FDR 85 years ago I mean the
president United States went to a
foreign country and attacked the Supreme
Court in front of a Spanish host law
professor Elizabeth Warren said it was
illegitimate we somebody committed a
felony and leaked a confidential Memo
from the court it's a it's a felony to
go out in front of a Justice's home we
had the Senate minority leader just two
years ago Chuck Schumer say that the
court and he named the justices by name
Tucker Justice Gorsuch and cabinet you
don't know what will hit you and he said
that they had reaped they had sold the
win and they reaped the Whirlwind what
did he mean by that they're going to
reap the Whirlwind and what was going to
hit them and now we have this court
packing scheme that arises it's part of
a larger landscape Tucker that the left
is a revolutionary it's like the French
Revolutionary Jacobin movement they
don't trust any Customs they don't honor
any any laws everything is fluid and
it's legal only to the extent that it's
useful so the 180 year filibuster that
they used to treasure as a minority
party in the Senate it's they want to
get rid of it the 150 person either 150
year nine person Supreme Court get rid
of it it's no longer useful they can't
have a republican Justice flip as they
did from Warren to David Suitor easily
anymore so the like adolescents they're
angry 50 state union we've had for 60
years bring in two more states to get
Senators same thing with a National
voting law to override the
Constitutional prerogative of each state
to set you know balloting laws and then
we have the 200 and well 32 year old
Electoral College wants the blue wall
fell like little kids they got angry and
said get rid of it so the the common
denominator is all of this is they look
at the law as what's useful for the
moment for a progressive agenda and when
that is no longer true then they try to
destroy the institution and that's what
they're doing and it's incumbent on
everybody to call them out for what they
are
yeah and to stop it if you can the
activist left is dangerous and people
need to stop it steps to protect
themselves and their families I
appreciate it uh Victorious Hansen as
always thank you
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight